معنى الان همم من القاهره ايمن سرور
المحامي والنشط الحقوقيه استاذ ايمن من
باريس اذا همم الاستاذ ايمن سرور المحامي
ونشاط الحقوقي اهلا وسهلا بك يا استاذ
ايمن سرور ان يتوقف معك عند قضيه سجين
السياسي المصري الابرز اذا على عبد الفتاح
وقضيته التي اثرت حتى قبل عقد مؤتمر
المناخ عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من
خلال اسرته ايضا الى اي مدى يمكن ان تمكن
كل هذه الدعوات وهذه المساعي الى الافراج
عن على عبد الفتاح
الحقن في ثلاث مسائل في منتهيه في مساله
علاء ومساله رمزيه علاء وما يمثلوا من
خلال خطاباته وما سرب او ما يعني
افادت به خطاباته لوالدته والاخته الرجل
لا يتحدث عن نفسه حتى من يتحدث عن اوضاع
كثر جدا راهم شخصيا يعاني نفسه معاناتهم
ومن ثم هو يدافع عن حاله وهي دي رمزيه
واهميته بصراحه الجزء الثاني هو مساله
صحيه لان الرجل بعد اضراب طويل عن الطعام
بطريقه معينه تقنيه جدا في تاجيل يصعب على
الكافرين حتى فهمها كل من يحاول مهاجمته
لن يفهم كيف يدير الرجلته الى اي همم دعم
خارجي هو جسده ومن ثم بدايه توقفه عن
تناول الماء يعني ان حالته الصحيه
حياته ليست فقط في خطر بل من الممكن ان
تنتهي حتى في اللحظات اللي احنا بنتكلم
فيها اضيفي على ذلك انه منذ الامس لم
تستطع والدته بزيارات الطبيعيه اليوميه ان
تحصل على خطاب منه ما يفيد بطريقه غير
مباشره وجوده على قيد الحياه او تطورات عن
حالته الصحيه وامتناع السلطات في مصر عن
التصريح رسميا حتى بهذه الحاله نعلق
الحياه حرام صور له او حتى اجراء لقاء معه
من خلال مجلس حتى الوطن او المجلس القومي
للانسان في مصر كل ده بيساوي ان في بيخوف
شديده ومن الطبيعي جدا انه يستغل المؤتمر
همم يعني همم
المناخ ليه الاوضاع الحقوقيه وغير
الحقوقيه هذه ان لم يكن يعني البشطاء
والدول تتحدث عن هذا في مثل هذا التوقيت
متى تتحدث عنه طيب استاذ همم ايمن قالت
والده علاء عبد الفتاح ان وضعه في السجن
غير معروف هو الذي ربما انقطع عن شرب
الماء قبل يومين كنت قد تحدث مع والدته
همم قالت لي ان رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
همم ربما او السلطات البيطريه طالما تحدث
عن وضعه لكن دون تقدم يذكر لماذا لا يفرش
عن على عبد الفتاح ما الذي يحول دون ذلك
ما حدش يعرف ما الذي في حوله دون ذلك والا
كنا عرفنا ايه اللي بين الافراج
انت محامي صراحه التهم الموجهه الى علاء
عبد الفتاح منذ ان وضع سجن ربما لا تعادل
المده السجنيه التي يقضيها هناك
في مصر سواء حكم عليهم او سواء في ذمه
الحبس الاحتياطي لعده سنوات تعتبر في حد
ذاتها عقاب دي ازمه حقيقيه دي لازمه
الرئيسيه لحقوق الانسان في مصر بشكل اساسي
ومعها ازمات اخرى ربما اكثر خطوره لكن
التركيز الان على هذا منهم في السجن بسبب
علاء ورمزته كما تحدثنا الاشكاليه
القضائيه ابتداء انما اذا تحدثنا على
القانون فا نحن تحدثنا بهذه المرات وحتى
خلال الاستضافه في قناتكم مشهورين تحدثنا
مئات المرات وبوضوحه وامثله
وبقضايا اننا نتحدث عن واحكام دون ادله
ومجرد اتهامات عامه وعدم وجود اا حقيقه حق
الدفاع وعدم وجود دفاع والامور كثيره جدا
يعني قتلت بحثا وقتلت كلاما وتعلامه جدا
كما يعلمها الاخرين في تقديري انه في ازمه
داخل النظام في مصر بما يتعلق باتخاذ قرار
الافران عن علاء لانه هنالك اتجاه واضح
شديد منذ ان جاء هذا النظام في مصر الى
السلطه وما اقول ليس عيبا وليس يعني اهانه
للنظام بالمره ولكنهم يتبنون فكره ان انا
لن نرضخ لاي ضغوط مهما كانت هذه نقطه نقطه
اخرى انهم يعتقدون تماما ان نعم فتاح ومن
مثله وهم كانوا اخرين بعضهم افرج عنهم
والبعض الاخر ما زالهم رموز دائما تذكرتي
ليه الثوره في 2011 ومن ثم مجرد وجودهم في
الخارج في يعني لهم اشكاليات كثيره ثم
للاسف الشديد عندهم تجارب يعني سيئه جدا
وانا في تقدير انهم دائما يخش الخروج من
هم مثل علاء لانهم سيتحدثون عن ما حدث
داخليا هنتحدي ان الرجل سيتحدث من خرج
بالفعل انا اتحدث عنها ان شاء الله يخرج
باذن الله لكن انا باتكلم عن اخرين ولن
اذكر اسماء حتى يعني لا يعني افتح باب
الجدال حولهم عندما خرجوا تحدثوا عن كل
الانتهاكات والمخالفات البدنيه والصحيه
والنفسيه والقانونيه التي وجهها في تقدير
ان النظام سيكسب كثيرا اذا افرج عن علاء
عبد الفتاح اليوم قبل غيرها جزيل الشكر لك
من باريس دائما سرور المحامي والنشط
الحقوقي شكرا جزيلا لك